(carnival music)
- Oh, you're good at that.
- Today I'm in New York,
and I'm gonna meet up with the band DNCE
and together, we're gonna
let their Twitter followers
decide their day.
It's gonna be lovely, we're
gonna have a really good time.
We're gonna dance, oh we're gonna dance.
(upbeat techno music)
- Hey!
- Hey, how's it going?
Hey I'm Keith.
- Hey.
- Nice to meet you Cole.
Joe.
- What's up how are you?
- Hello!
- JinJoo.
Jack, all the way over there.
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
Thanks for agreeing to do this.
I know it's tough to let
Twitter decide everything you're gonna do.
The whole day we'll send out Tweets
they're gonna decide what you do next.
- I'm in.
- I figured first,
since we have such a big day ahead of us,
let's get some coffee!
- Right?
- Okay, let's do that.
- So can I get a phone?
Can I grab a phone?
- Yeah, sure.
- Oh yeah, fanny-pack phone's better.
- Oh, fanny pack phone is the way to go.
Alright, so I'm gonna send
out a Tweet real quick,
that we are getting coffee.
Let's say they'll have you choose between
singing your order, helping
clear away peoples garbage,
or buying a bunch of
coffee and handing it out.
So I'm gonna send this out.
We're gonna put five minutes on this poll.
And there we go.
And now we wait.
(alarm ticking)
They chose handing out coffees,
so guys, give out some coffee!
- [JinJoo] You guys want some coffee?
- [Man] Thank you very much,
you're very kind, thank you.
- You want a free coffee bud?
You guys want a free coffee?
- [Man] You're one of the
Jonas Brothers, right?
- You want a free coffee?
- No thank you.
It's so good.
It's not good when you stand
in front of a coffee shop
asking if people want coffee
- You're right.
- Hi!
- There's a lot of people coming.
- Do you want some coffee?
- [Woman] Thanks.
- Yeah!
- Have a good day!
- Alright, JinJoo gave away free coffee!
- [Man] Free coffee?
Alright.
- [Cole] That's a smart man right there.
- Alright.
(cheering)
- I'm also in DNCE.
I wanted to surprise you.
We're going to the Knicks game!
- What?
(cheering)
- We're going to the Knicks game!
- Seriously?
- Get in the--
Yes, get in the car, we'll do
some more things from there.
We're going to Madison Square Garden.
Get in the car, get in the car DNCE.
From the car, should we, at intersections,
compliment people?
Sing to people, or blow kisses to people?
- Yeah yeah, let's do it.
- [Keith] Oh, people want
you to sing to people.
Classic.
♫ JinJoo has poor taste in men
- Cole, I gotta say.
You have such a beautiful voice.
Do you not put him on as
front vocals on everything?
- It's in the works.
- It's beautiful.
It's so good.
But we're almost to MSG,
so I wanted to figure out,
what are you guys gonna do
right when you get there?
Y'know, there's gonna be fans outside.
We're headed to MSG.
When we get there, should we
have people take our pictures,
or do the Andy Challenge?
- Andy, no that's a Toy Story thing man.
- Oh it's a Toy, oh, oh yeah!
That's when you drop.
- Somebody screams Andy
and then you drop.
- Oh, and then you drop.
(distorted techno music)
Guys, Andy's coming!
- Oh no!
Oh no!
- We're good, we're good, everybody good?
Everybody good, everybody good?
Everybody still a toy?
Awesome, okay great let's go.
(deep techno music)
Over there, obviously,
incredible basketball.
Over here, we have a special challenge.
Twitter really wanted you guys to dance,
specifically to your
new single Body Moves.
So I got the Knicks City
Dancers to meet you, to dance.
So, we're gonna Tweet out either
that they're gonna teach
you guys a new dance,
you're gonna teach them a new dance,
or nobody's gonna learn anything,
you're just gonna throw
down in a dance battle.
- Perfect.
- Sound good?
- Yeah, it's fine.
- Great, let's do it.
Alright guys,
so turns out Twitter decided
you'd have a dance battle.
Let's see how your body moves.
(ding)
Hit it.
♫ Come and roll with me,
we'll rock them body moves
♫ Me and you
♫ Oh, just a little bit
♫ Body moves
♫ Yeah, just a little bit, ow
♫ Coming home with me,
oh baby, let it loose
♫ Me and you
♫ Oh, just a little bit
♫ Body moves
♫ Yeah, just a little bit
- Oh wow, wow!
Wow!
Synchronized avant-garde, I
have never seen it before.
You were tremendous,
obviously you actually won,
but for the purpose of
the video, DNCE won.
Congratulations!
Great work!
Are you guys hungry after that?
- Starvation station.
- I feel like, oh my gosh
you worked up such a hunger.
- I could go for
some six-year-old food.
- I'm hungry all the time.
- Let's choose between all the candy,
all the popcorn, and all the ice cream.
- Wow.
- Sound good?
- [Joe] Love it.
- And the next thing you'll see is
us slow-mo eating gorgeous food.
God, what is happening, what is happening.
(uplifting orchestral music)
(lip smacking)
- Oh, you're good at that.
- Alright DNCE.
I hate to say it but our
time has drawn to a close.
We had so much fun.
- All good things
must come to an end.
- They really do, they do all end.
But we don't know how they end.
So I'm gonna send out one final Tweet
asking Twitter how does this video end?
A rom-com ending, a where are they now,
a jump into a freeze-frame,
or a tearful goodbye.
And there we go, and now we wait.
- And now we wait.
♫ Five minutes in the poll
- Okay so I just got home,
and I was looking through my phone
to grab screen-grabs of all the Tweets,
and then I realized that
the one that I thought
won the end of the video didn't win.
I accidentally chose
the second place winner,
but y'know, in today's climate
sometimes the popular
vote just doesn't win,
and you get what you get.
So here's what you get.
- You're a big, mean,
glasses-wearing jerk.
- No I'm not, why would--
- We saw you hanging
out with another band.
- That's right.
- [Joe] How could you
do this to our hearts?
- It wasn't like that,
no you don't understand.
- We're done with you, we're done.
- This is over.
- No you don't understand.
- Save it.
- If you're gonna be that way
then fine!
- Save it!
- Fine, be that way!
(screeching)
Fine, be that way!
- Wait!
(sobbing)
Wait!
Keith!
- We were kidding!
- I can still smell you.
- It's fine guys, he's gone.
- Oh man!
(panting)
- Wait!
Wait!
I can make it...
They're really gone.
Bye DNCE.